I feel like and correct me if I'm wrong
there's a lot to it because that'd be
four in a row for Drew Dober three for
you and you beat a ranked opponent you
get put in the top 15 but also both of
you have been calling out Patty pimlet
for quite some time I feel like the
winner of this probably fights Patty
pimlet yeah definitely I mean once I uh
handle Dober I'm gonna beat up Patty
it's only a matter of time and now
you're a WWE Fan I would assume you get
on that mic and give us one hell of a
promo with your WWE knowledge and call
out Patty and that's probably gonna be
the talk of UFC 288 yeah yeah that
sounds about right you know I just gotta
like a lot of people ask me they're like
oh do you like prepare what you're gonna
say after the fight no no I don't like
yeah like I'm so dialed in like I'm
focused on the fight focus on Dober and
then we we move on to uh to serve in
Patty pemblet some Humble Pie